President Trump plans to meet at the
White House later today with the North
Korean official described as Kim Jong
Un's right-hand man kim jong-chul is his
name he will deliver a letter from the
North Korean leader he met yesterday
with Secretary of State mark Mike Pompeo
about a potential nuclear summit our two
countries face a pivotal moment in our
relationship in which it could be
nothing short of tragic to let this
opportunity go to waste
major Garrett is at the White House with
more on this story major good morning
good morning the Secretary of State also
said the summit will occur and progress
can be made but only if North Korea is
prepared to make an unprecedented
strategic shift away from nuclear
weapons now the arrival of kim
yeongcheol
the highest-ranking North Korean to come
to this White House in nearly two
decades does suggest the possibility the
North is at least willing to explore a
new relationship with the US hopefully
we'll have a meeting on the 12th
president Trump growing more familiar
with the complex negotiations ahead
acknowledged a nuclear deal with North
Korea could require a summit and much
more doesn't mean it gets all done at
one meeting maybe you have to have a
second or a third and maybe we'll have
none today's expected meeting with
dictator Kim Jong Un's close aide kim
yong-chul signals progress in summit
talks the White House expects Kim will
deliver a letter from Kim jong-un a
response perhaps to mr. Trump when he
wrote kim jungeun canceling the
singapore summit the president then
cited new north korean hostility but
urged the North Korean leader to quote
call me or write if you change your mind
kim yong-chul is a top regime figure he
was sanctioned by the Obama
administration for his alleged
involvement in approving the North
Korean hack of Sony Pictures
Entertainment in 2014 make no mistake
about it there remains a great deal of
work to do
after meeting with Kim in New York
Thursday Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
said tough talks lie ahead the US wants
verifiable and irreversible
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
North Korea wants economic sanctions
lifted the pace and sequence of both
divide the two nations
Pompeyo said the two sides came closer
to nailing down a
it does no good if we're in a place
where we don't think there's real
opportunity to place them together we've
made real progress towards that in the
last 72 hours pressure is already
building on the administration to ease
those economic sanctions on North Korea
the White House wary of decades of
broken promises from North Korea on the
nuclear weapons questions wants to see
much more tangible evidence of
disarmament first Nora that evidence
important major thank you so much